hundreds of students in North Las Vegas
got a glimpse of what their future could
look like if they decided to become a
first responder Somerset Academy
centennial and commerce held its annual
tribute to First Responders and heroes
and they invited 8 news now to be a part
of it 8 news now reporter Victoria Saha
tells us what this day meant to the kids
from firefighters to police to EMTs
they all play an important role to our
community they all work together to help
save the world and make sure everyone
being the first to respond and to react
I learned how all the heroes saved the
world hey there along with First
Responders news crews are on scene
bringing you the latest information
throughout the pandemic you delivered us
news you put yourselves in your family
at risso in my opinion it was absolutely
mind mandatory for eight news now to
show up Mitchell buswell with Somerset
Academy North Las Vegas organized the
event and wants to make a difference in
the lives of his students Inspire our
kids to do more than what they think
they can do and see themselves in what
these workers do letting them know their
options are endless there are a lot of
jobs out there are that are trying to
help other people in our in our state
and Country do you think we were able to
inspire some of your kiddos too oh well
absolutely they're arguing now I'm going
to be a news reporter
whether it's holding a microphone one
day or becoming a first responder the
students here are leaving the event
feeling inspired about who they may
become one day in North Las Vegas
Victoria Saha 8 News Now